you know I don't think I'm the only one
with a little bit of PTSD these days for
a lot of us that live through those
really dark days suddenly here we are
again with a virus you can't see
randomly affecting people life being put
on hold all sorts of things changing
around the time of the lockdown here in
San Francisco it suddenly occurred to me
that this is going to be at the second
pandemic of my life and I really no one
should have to live through more than
one all those years ago in San Francisco
and then in the early 80s and mid 80s
there's a really dark time I had just
finished Stanford Business School and
had taken care of a friend and a
classmate who died during school and
moved up to San Francisco Oh without
really thinking much about a career and
a job a little a little heartbroken and
a little bit lost and kind of stumbled
into the middle of an epidemic the
Castro back then was horrible he walked
down the street and you'd pass dozens of
people who you knew you were probably
never gonna see again the country didn't
seem to be responding or didn't seem to
be caring when some friends and I
started the it's Memorial Quilt it was
really it was really a cry for help it
was a really a way to be heard at a time
when we all thought we were going to die
alone and forgotten a friend of a friend
Cleve Jones came to me in 1987 and said
he had this crazy idea for a quilt and
some way to reach middle America with
something that's not threatening and
feels warm and comforting and you think
of your grandmother when someone says
quilt and that wasn't the world we were
living in who with AIDS right then it
was a much different world where people
were they either there's you and there's
Austin we don't have it and you do and
that's all there is to it almost
immediately I thought this is an idea
that's really going to resume we said we
were going to do that first display at
the march on Washington for gay and
lesbian rights in October of 87 like 4
months after we decided to start
building this thing which was crazy and
I think I thought we would do this for a
little while and we make our point and
that would be the end and I don't think
we were prepared for the beauty of the
quilts we had been making something that
were basically bed sheets to make a
protest statement and suddenly we had
mothers all over the country
as panels for their dead son expecting
us to preserve them and care for them in
perpetuity I never thought it would
become my life's work but it has become
my life's work you know in the middle of
all of this Cove it when it first
happened I wasn't the only one that was
kind of looking for a way to be helpful
a way to do something which has always
been kind of my mode Gert McMullen who'd
been very involved in in sewing together
many of the panels in the quilt for
years was feeling the same way she used
to be able to go into hospital rooms in
the 80s and be with dying friends he
just couldn't stand that she couldn't
touch people and she couldn't be up
close to people finally she said you
know I'm gonna go into the workshop it's
empty there's nobody else there and I'm
gonna start making some face masks and
we can give him away to people I made a
phone call to an old friend and it
turned out she was working at an agency
that was desperate for masks this
project has really opened my eyes to see
how many vulnerable and at-risk
populations there are in an epidemic
like this in a homeless shelter in a
youth rehab program people are right
there up close with each other and you
can't get that kind of distance the AIDS
Memorial Quilt has gone from a protest
banner and something we were gonna take
to Washington to make a difference for
one day - a national treasure I mean
it's the largest Community Arts Project
in the world more people have worked on
the quilt and built the pyramids and a
lot of what we did at the time was not
just the fabric we inspired people to do
something anything to express what they
were going through to tell their stories
and I think now about where we are with
this mask project and it's the same
thing we may make two or three thousand
masks and that may save some lives I'd
much rather have this be a catalyst for
other people to feel like I can find
something to do I can get out of my
house and go help stuff food at the food
bank if we can do something simple like
make masks you can do something simple
like find a way to be helpful and that's
what I'd much rather be remembered for
that meeting that catalyst than for just
doing some sewing
you